[Music]
oh God
[Applause]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by James Corden he's
the 12-time Emmy award-winning host of
The Late Late Show with James Corden and
he has a brand new project on the way as
well starring alongside Sally Hawkins
and the dark comedy drama series mammals
which is set to release on Prime video
November 11th James Corden welcome to
the show thank you for having me how are
you around spicy food before we get
started
um so I'm in for the challenge
plus I really like you and my son thinks
that this is just like the coolest he
thinks there's nothing we've done on The
Late Late Show which even comes close to
being as good as this in terms of viral
moments so when I told him he was like
oh wow
but now I'm here and you can't escape it
yeah I'm I'm really yeah I'm genuinely
quite scared by it scared by all of it
thank you
foreign
[Music]
right well you don't know unless you try
it this will be like your new favorite
food
oh that's fantastic
that's what I'm saying
that's great this has been brilliant
thanks man
cheers guys I did it I crushed it let's
go
[Music]
so in mammals you play the role of Jamie
and Michelin starred Chef whose life
begins to unravel when he discovers a
shocking secret about his pregnant wife
what was the draw or pull for this
particular project for you like have you
long been yearning for a chance to
return to dramatic acting Roots the
thing with this show it's written by a
playwright called Jeff Butterworth who
is a hero of yours yeah he wrote
Skyfall and Ford vs Ferrari the new
Indiana Jones uh he also has written his
last two plays have won Tony Awards and
Olivier Woods a play called Jerusalem a
play called the ferryman
they're the best Knights I've ever
spent in a theater watching those shows
and we actually met in New York he said
look I wrote this show a few years ago
could you do it and I read it and I just
emailed him back straight back and I was
like yes I mean it's the most excited
I've ever been reading a script ever
like I'm so I'm so proud of it as a show
I really am
I'm trying to watch how you're eating it
um you're trying to avoid some lip
touching would that be fair maybe or
maybe I'm like evening it out you know
like front half maybe work this side a
little bit left side work this side a
little bit you don't want the sides you
know 19 Seasons 19 Seasons you learn the
tricks you're working sides of your
mouth
NFL coach a balanced attack yeah you're
playing defense and then you're like go
hit him
wow jeez
again
very pleasant lovely
very pleasant so far so far
very pleasant I'm I'm I would go so far
as I'm having a nice time there we go
we'll see if we can keep it going
so from my understanding hot wings and
carpool karaoke have somewhat similar
origin stories in that you knew you had
something special the second that you
uttered the name and the concept but the
real challenge began when you actually
had to start booking it what is it that
publicist maybe didn't connect or didn't
see about it in the original pitch it
was everything really like I've I've so
certain that we had a good idea I just I
just knew that like oh this makes sense
I get it I'm sure the way that you
thought about this like I remember
reading about you saying like
people open up
in an environment where they're feeling
uncomfortable it's very difficult to
keep your guard up when you're like and
you're sharing something together like I
think this would be very very different
if you sat there and just got the guests
to eat and you didn't right yeah it's
something there's camaraderie in it that
I can already feel when we're doing this
and so there's something about taking
someone and placing them completely on
their own in an environment that is so
recognizable to us
we sing Our lungs out in the car along
to the radio and seeing someone doing
something in the very same way that we
do it I think is quite humanizing and I
think that's what that's what you've
done so brilliantly here is it's a very
very humanizing segment you know
[Music]
now which part of your mouth are you
going to work for this I'm bouncing over
to the left bouncing to the left yeah
yeah
[Music]
I'm back left
smart you know I know that you're a
rookie but that's a veteran move right
there I'm back left watch this watch
this
yeah
right there I'm about right you say my
first rodeo
when we had Russell Brand on the show he
taught me the chant up your ass up your
ass stick your blue flag up your ass yes
as a fellow West Ham supporter do you
have a favorite song or chance to scream
from The Terraces
I actually had the experience
I think of what it feels like to be like
a West Ham manager
I'd gone to Emirates Stadium to watch
West Ham play Arsenal and I was sat
right above the West Ham fans
and one started chanting one James
Corden there's only one James Corden and
I was like oh my God I couldn't believe
it I was laughing I was like these are
like I used to sit with these people in
like the lower Bobby Moore abton Park I
can't believe this then one of them said
uh Cordon give us a song called and
called and give us a song and there's a
back and forth
song that West Ham fans singing about oh
East London oh East London is wonderful
is wonderful uh so we sang that I
started it they turned it back I was
like this is amazing and then uh and
then someone just went Gordon is a
wanker Coral is a wanker
and then they all started so I was like
whoa that's a good turn that really
should to go and then one of them
started singing uh get your tits out for
the lads oh wow I really had a moment I
imagine that's what it feels like to be
West Ham manager you win three games the
fans are like you're amazing and then
immediately you're like you're dead and
uh yeah it was a lesson in uh just you
know being uh
not taking everything with a bag of salt
you know
Los Calientes now you said that like
it's turning up a notch
I'm again working the back left
I see it
but so far you're doing good I'm gonna
try and David Blaine it
just I'm just gonna try and playing it
no I'm just gonna try you know David
Blaine was on our show last week right
two weeks ago same with ours actually
and I never I never know what he's gonna
do the trick because I I love the
element of surprise of it he enjoys that
too
so he comes on the show and he just goes
to me do you trust me he makes me take
out a hundred dollar bill and he lights
it on fire and pours a mug of water on
the ash of the hundred dollar bill and
then he goes to me drink it so I drink
it right I drink the whole thing he then
does the sketch it's amazing there's a
bird comes out lands on the stage
holding a hundred dollar bill with the
exact same
Security numbers when it's crazy
as soon as we go to break he goes
dude I can't believe you drunk that
and our producer Rob runs up and goes
you weren't going to drink it you
weren't meant to drink the water I'm
like well
why'd you give me your heads up yeah
nobody said and I go to David Lane I go
am I gonna am I gonna be all right am I
gonna be okay he goes yeah yeah he goes
you know when you put a cigarette out on
your tongue it's no worse and I was like
um okay because that's a reference point
that lots of people are aware you know
like oh yeah of course yeah did it on
Friday yeah
so I'm gonna blame it blame it okay here
we go
okay I feel like we're about I felt like
we're in the we're in the change Zone
I feel
probably honest as a taste that's
delicious
you know it set my taste buds to light
they're not lying
but it's they've put it on quite a low
flame you know they've put it on a nice
it's a simmer yeah a nice pleasant slow
rope nice slow roast nice slow roast
yeah we can put this on leave it all day
the meat's gonna fall off the bone come
6 p.m all right James we have a very
cream segment on our show called explain
that gram where we do a deep dive on our
guests and scramble interesting pictures
that need more contact so I'll show you
the picture over here on the laptop you
just tell us the bigger story laptop
please thank you Bill you're welcome I
mean I think it is worth saying that I
almost never post on Instagram yeah
actually
um side note we went into the Gettys
because also they're easily they're
easier to clear in post okay but that's
that's the that's a hot one secret all
right that's okay
don't you worry about that do you
remember the moment they gave you the
biggest Adrenaline Rush while ripping
through the sky in a 40s era fighter jet
flown by Tom Cruise I.T
it's a Tom code
and you know it's Tom Cruise so he just
goes James listen to me I am never ever
gonna put your life in danger you just
gotta trust me you know it's all like
that and what was amazing and what he
did say that really did put me at ease
was he said the reason we have to do it
now is I'm flying every day I'm
completely match fit the most terrifying
bit
he just went okay you ready
and I was like for what and I can't
remember what he called it like a death
roll or something where basically the
plane just goes
what should I do with the wing yeah the
plane goes it's you're here and and
you're up this way and it just goes like
this
oh and twists
and
you're like
like falling to the to the and you can
see the Earth
and you're in an old plane so it's
really hot
and you can't help but just go
about that then he pulls you back up and
like and he's of course just cracking up
because he just thinks this
is hilarious there was a lot going
through my mind when I did it a lot of
it was like if something happens
bad
for the rest of their lives my children
might be somewhere
and people will go
do you know who that is
their dad killed Tom Cruise
but that would be the takeaway my my
death would just be irrelevant it would
just be the fact that I it's because of
me a segment for my show I killed the
greatest movie star perhaps of all time
and they would have to live with that
[Music]
smells a bit different no
okay I'm going in
there's no chewing strategy that works
at a time like this right it's just all
out attack now
oh okay
okay I see what you do here you loved me
yep
[Applause]
oh God
so since the 1950s hosting a network TV
show I think was a job that most people
considered a lifetime appointment but
that's obviously a thing of the past
with multiple hosts in the last couple
years including yourself announcing
imminent departures do you have a take
on the endless inks build the conjecture
and questioning about the future of late
night
you know historically the slot that I'm
in that 12 30 slot has been like
students snoners Stoners insomniacs
night shift workers that's that's your
key demographic as far as I can work out
all of those people are still watching
things they're just not really reaching
for the button to go like what time is
it we should put that on and I think
this probably happened before I started
the late lecture was starting to happen
I've certainly felt it happen while
we're doing it the the nature of them
has changed whereas like what it used to
be is like
this was the only place you'd ever see
right these huge stars as themselves you
know and now like
you you can open your phone and you can
see some of the biggest stars in the
world in their house
talking to you from their kitchen so
suddenly the notion of a talk show is
somehow removed that
that acts where you're adding an
additional step where you're like well
that's not I just saw you in the gym
walking down a road you know I've seen
you at your most human so it it's it's
it's a tricky thing as like a well of
course like a traditional talk show host
to to sort of
think about in combat whereas I think
something like this feels completely
organic because I think it came from a
really organic place of what you wanted
to do you know look it used to be how
many networks were there in America
before right three it's it's now there's
just all of these places to try and sell
whatever it is you're trying to do you
know and it's it's a very very
interesting time uh
in that sort of traditional linear
television because I think I I still
think it has value
it's just
I don't know trying to figure that out I
think is a bit of a Minefield I do
Karma source so does that mean it's
karma for things that my mouth may have
done in the past perhaps
let's let's hit the Disco
wow
I'm just looking in the eyes
I'm so stupid I know but now it seems
like such a distant memory when you were
like I'm the first three Wings you're
like oh this is crazy I know I'm gonna
let me swallow it my body's going don't
do this
my tongue's trying to get rid of it
okay go ahead
whoa
you got it though
somehow some way
Frozen in Time
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I know
I know
had some bass
so in the carpool karaoke episode
featuring Paul McCartney he dropped I
know I know I know I know
what we actually sent it around to all
of our team because it was inspiring to
see what probably went into that episode
on a production level was there anything
in that episode you remember fighting
for even though it seemed impossible to
pull off oh everything
oh so I'm glad you reached for the milk
that makes me feel better because look
where I'm at I know I know but you're
trying to keep up I'm trying to keep up
it was tough to get him to do it you
know he was in he was out brilliantly he
said okay fine I'll do it and he said to
me uh
I don't want to go in my house
I don't want to go in my house I haven't
been in there
since I left when I was I think it was
18 or 19.
and I just remember going to him I just
said Paul your only day's work today is
to have a great time if you don't want
to go in your house we will of course we
won't go in your house but let's not
rule it out now
let's see how we feel when we get there
and if we get there
and you don't feel comfortable you're
not having a good time you don't want to
do it give me a look and I'll drive on
and I'll take the blame
so you can actually see it on the bit I
go
should we go in he goes yeah why not and
we go in and
I'll always be really really proud of
that and Incredibly grateful to Paul for
taking a leap with us really and
speaking of going for it
these Segways you've got these Segways
you've got I know that you think they're
Charming they're not they're getting
annoying
and speaking of shedding your pants
let's move on to this
okay
I never get used to this one either
oh my God
[ __ ] I know
I know
I got you doggy I know
so you performed at the National Theater
how can you pretend like this isn't
happening how can you just go back to
like performing at the National Theater
when so I always just like come on man's
telling me I'm going to die right right
I ignore the absurdity of this show
that's how that's a good idea I just
always approach it as if we're not even
eating I write it as if we're not even
exactly none of us exactly we're all
just
but I'm just even connected right maybe
we're just a simulation my tongue
doesn't know what's happening right
that's the best way I can describe it
confusion my tongue is sending messages
to my brain saying I think you should go
to the hospital right right and my
body's going don't be silly none of us
are even here we're all dust so you've
performed at the National Theater hosted
a late night talk show and were even
appointed an Obe but do you ever think
that your greatest cultural contribution
might have been smithy's Indian takeout
order and Gavin and Stacy it might be
certainly to some people yes for sure do
you remember the order
Chromebook
came and mushroom rice bag of chips and
nine papadums is that it yeah
what's up and then we're all just gonna
whoa hang on why wait
why have we all gotta why are we all
just because it's nice no it's not not
for me
because I can guarantee I can guarantee
somebody here probably Stacy has ordered
a comma Am I Wrong Mick am I wrong no
you're right actually she has right and
that's pointless to me it's futile
because I won't touch it but I can
guarantee that Pete is already thinking
about my bonus Pete have you thought
about my bonus
well yeah right there my bonus if you
want a booner order a buner now I've had
enough of it it's the same when I went
out with Chinese in his business last
week they're all digging into my ago and
you're really nice I'm like yes it is
that's why I ordered it in fact forget
it I want no part of it I ordered my own
and I'll eat it in the car
nice yeah one of my is so much fun that
oh yeah I'm surprised I remember that
much
unique garlic oh geez
now now it's like we're coming up with
tricks
you know I'm chewing very fast
is what I've realized
like I've taken quite a lot of cocaine
Jar's going
let me tell you about my dad
[Laughter]
so hang on this is 19 seasons
how many episodes a season
12 episodes a season
and in the early ones we did like we had
one see like season two was like 55
episodes right we were just like it
looks like because they remember what it
was like to work on it like all of like
those are my day ones yeah my day ones
you know it's like they've been along
for this entire journey and like season
two we just were like we gotta turn out
episodes we gotta turn out yeah so it's
like we just did something we just gotta
hit we just got everything every
Wednesday every Wednesday exactly
exactly hit that same time 11 A.M so
that the audience becomes conditioned to
like know that at this time like this is
what you whatever so we were just like
let's run it up run it up run it and the
idea we went through a similar thing
with our show where we would just try
like I think we've done
1150 shows
I think we've done
65 70 carpools something like that
but we went through a stage of like
let's try and do as many as we can and
then as soon as it got to a point it's
like okay well now we just need to kind
of protect it right try and keep it in
some rarefied air I get it uniquely
all right James Corden
the last step the last dab
nice Shake good fundamentals right there
good fundament thank you
[Music]
you don't have to if you don't want to
[ __ ] you oh
cheers
to you James hang them I know how much
are they so much too much yeah but we're
here
[Music]
[Music]
I wonder who I'll be after this all
right it's a transformative
baptism by fire yeah
[Music]
Born Again out of the hot sauce to you
James Corden I'm gonna tell you in case
in case this does kill me
not immediately but tonight
absolutely loved every single second
it's so good at this you're so brilliant
at it and everyone was like it's cool
Sean's gonna take you through it I was
like okay it's completely right you are
absolutely brilliant at this you should
be so proud of thank you James
thank you
and speaking of being proud
I know you walked in here I'm having no
confidence in yourself but look at you
taking on the wings of death and still
on your feet and only one more question
before we close things up what I want to
do is draw a connection to this
experience right now in your Memoir may
I have your attention please where you
begin every chapter by giving out the
precise atmospheric conditions in order
to optimize the read so if someone is
watching this episode of hot ones with
James Corden do you have in your mind a
best musical accompaniment
[Music]
I do I absolutely do there's a song
I just either listened to it before or
after
it's called go easy kid by Monica Martin
and James Blake I think it's the best
song of the year
there's the refrain says go easy kid
It's Only Rock and Roll
and at the end of the song
they say yeah go easy kid in 20 years
kid you're gonna look back and wish you
grabbed it all by the throat
said [ __ ] it
It's Only Rock and Roll
Pike drop and look at you James Gordon
taking on the wings of death living to
tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do or roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
uh I have a new show it's called mammals
it's on Prime video November the 11th
[Music]
I'm as proud of it as anything I've ever
done
and uh
you know
none of us are here it's all dust
he did it
that was such fun did you have a good
time oh it was amazing I absolutely love
it thank you so much
hey what's going on hot wings fans we
brought the heat to the freezer aisle
with our hot ones boneless chicken bites
and use smash sales records and all of
our wildest expectations so what did we
do we made more that's right we are in
with five new flavors of hot one's
boneless chicken bites and five new ways
for you to bring hot ones home from the
classic to the classic garlic Fresno
Edition to the Los Calientes Trio of
flavor Verde Rojo Barbacoa visit
hotoneschallenge.com for more
information and to find a store near you
hot ones boneless chicken bites you're
in the hot seat now